[Music]
today's question comes from jennifer in
tennessee lately when i buy things
online i see that there's an option to
break the cost up in payments rather
than paying in full i'm not sure if it's
a good idea to take advantage of these
offers is doing this the same thing as
putting something on layaway at the
store
this is an interesting question i'll be
honest george i don't know i don't know
the terms around this i'm sure you do
this is fine print material this is your
specialty this got me riled up so you're
ready we just we just did a recent
episode of this on the fine print it's
called after pay a firm klarna should
you buy now pay later say that again you
lost me what these are the names of
companies after pay affirm klarna these
are the names you see below
should you buy now pay later and we dug
into this um and let me tell you
it's not good i can tell but that's not
good
first of all their marketing is
hilarious because they say they want to
create financial freedom for their
customers by chaining them to payments
uh and here's the company klarna here's
what they claim to retailers because
that's who their their target demo is
you'll spend 45 percent more if you use
a buy now pay later service on your
website wow so every retailer in america
is going absolutely you can be on my
website and we'll give you a cut or
we'll pay the fee whatever that looks
like
so
to your question jennifer
no it's not a good idea to quote take
advantage they are taking advantage of
you so we tell people to budget save up
pay cash i know it can be tempting when
you've got a hundred dollars in the cart
and they say hey what if you just paid
25 today free up that budget free up the
money in the budget way wiser no this is
payments this is debt and uh it's even
worse than layaway because you get it
now and so there's this element of
urgency that's just like well i already
got it yeah and i'll just be stuck with
the payments for another four months
and so it just i want to rally against
this culture of consumerism that says i
want it now prime now two hours now i
don't care if i don't have the money i
want it now so stay away from buy now
pay later services only pay for it if
you can afford it in cash with a debit
card that kind of thing the thing that i
think is just so important for people to
remember behind any of these whether
it's credit card points flyer miles
rewards buy now pay later break it up in
payments guys you just need to remember
these people
are not
trying to help you they're not your
friend they are not doing this out of
the goodness of their sweet little
hearts because they're just so generous
no they're doing it because there is
something in it for them which is
usually interest which is usually
spending more which is usually something
that helps them and hurts you they are
not trying to help you and so i just uh
it's good to remember that credit card
companies are not in these giant
buildings spending billions of dollars a
year on advertising because they're just
losing money on the deal here yeah
you're the one losing money yep you can
go check out that episode of the fine
print wherever you listen to podcasts